the parani indigenous Village is in
mourning
family members receive the body of a
woman she had been suffering from
tuberculosis
days earlier she was taken to the
nearest hospital some three hours away
by helicopter
even with treatment it was too late
we only have medicine here for simple
illnesses like colds and stomach aches
or to stabilize a patient until we get
outside help anything serious can only
be treated in the city the Javari Valley
in the heart of Brazil's Amazon is the
size of Austria there are no roads
traveling great distances in this remote
area is only possible by water or air
but there are a handful of small Health
outposts like this one
[Music]
we communicate wire radio with six other
villages to coordinate the medical
Logistics it's complicated we need 1 500
liters of gasoline to transport patients
by boat and it's a three to four days
trip to the nearest hospital fuel prices
went up and resources are scarce the
seven tribes of the Javari Valley who
have had contact with Outsiders are now
dealing with new diseases malaria
hepatitis and even HIV
but poisonous snakes a part of their
habitat also pose a serious threat snake
bites account for hundreds of deaths and
amputations each year a victim of snake
bite needs immediate medical attention
helicopters often aren't available they
can't fly in bad weather or land in the
middle of the Jungle it took me two days
by foot to reach a man who had been
bitten twice in the leg I had the serum
with me but he died eight hours later
many victims are bitten during Hunting
Expeditions like this one
the indigenous people prefer to treat
snake bites with centuries-old
traditional healing practices
but local herbs have proven to be less
effective than anti-venom serum produced
by Laboratories
medications that must be kept in a
refrigerator
something villages with no electricity
don't have and can't afford and even
when doctors here are able to make an
early diagnosis and guarantee the
transportation of the sick to the
nearest hospital they still face another
challenge dealing with the restrictions
imposed by the beliefs and culture of
the indigenous people many villagers
resist the idea of transporting their
relatives for treatment
the korubus who have had little contact
with Outsiders are more wary than others
they're afraid of leaving their homes to
an unknown place so we have to take the
patient and all of his family with us to
a hospital where they may be exposed to
other diseases putting the rest of the
village at risk the best solution is to
have a floating Hospital on the river to
attend them the Javari peoples want the
government to train their own tribesmen
as doctors and nurses but that is
something that may take a long time and
persuasion
Valley Brazil